mitch mcconnell is
a special kind of hypocritical piece of
[ __ ] he comes out
he calls the ideas that marjorie taylor
green
has is loony
basically calling her a nut case and
specifically calling her a cancer
in the party well
you have been the leader of the party
for a long time
[ __ ] i remember a mitch
mcconnell and i'm old enough to remember
this
i remember mitch mcconnell sitting on a
national interview
talking about president barack obama
and saying that the republican party's
number one
priority was to get rid
of barack obama and make sure he's a
one-term president
that was after the midterms in 2010
i was almost 11 years ago folks
that this guy was starting this [ __ ]
he perpetuated this this is not
his his concern back in 2010 wasn't the
economy
it wasn't it wasn't to make sure that
people had affordable health care
i mean you have to remember the position
that our economy in our and the
unemployment rate was
back during 2010 when he even said this
and the reason why he said it is because
barack obama is a black dude
that's why and we're standing around
wondering
why why marjorie taylor green a lady
who believes that there are jewish space
lasers
that cause forest fires
is a member of congress
and that donald trump backs her a
hundred percent
where the [ __ ] were you in 2016 mitch
mcconnell
when you were talking about loony [ __ ]
and nut bags and nut cases and cancers
to our party
where were you then huh
marjorie taylor green is not the cancer
she is only a symptom of the disease
that mitch mcconnell
is on this republican party and and
people like
mitch mcconnell and they're really
circling the wagons here because
they really they're starting to see
their party to to crumble
out from underneath them with low and
low lauren bo burton marjorie taylor
green
mo brooks josh holly ted cruz these
[ __ ] nut bags
lindsey graham says today oh why i i
haven't seen the videos that she said
that stuff in
her i didn't see them videos
sound familiar i didn't see him tweet
that i don't read twitter
i don't take that seriously
you [ __ ] better wake up
actually you know the point here is i
think they've done lost their party
it's over it's over we're we're we're in
the in
in the second act of this thing folks
the second act of the republican party
being split
and mitch mcconnell is desperately
trying to hang on to the gop
he's backing liz cheney uh kevin
mccarthy runs down to mar-a-lago and
kisses the ring of donald trump
uh marjorie taylor-green kisses the ring
of donald trump
ties to donald trump it's obvious what's
happening here
mitch mcconnell was trying to to support
liz cheney and give her room
uh to possibly become the minority
leader in the house as opposed to be
ousted
uh the second in charge steve scalise is
is not can't decide which side he's on
does do he
does he want to keep his crazy
constituents happy does he want to keep
the q and honors on his side
the vote the q anon voters or does he
want to go back to the old gop
john dune john thune has the nerve to
say today
that the gop has to decide
it has to decide whether it wants to be
the party of small
government physical responsibility
pro-life freedom with power
for power or does it want to be
the party of q and on conspiracy
theories well you
[ __ ] done sold that out you
already made your decision
the bed has been made you have to
[ __ ] sleep in it now
there's no changing this these
[ __ ] loopy q and on people aren't
going anywhere
and the democrats in the house tell the
republicans rightfully so
because they're not going to they're not
going to remove uh
marjorie taylor green from the house
they're not going to expel her
they couldn't get enough members to vote
to vote to expel her
because all these members are beholden
to these nut bag trumpers
that vote for them in their districts
they got these districts so
jerrymandered up
that the only way to win is to placate
to these [ __ ]
and their dumb stupid [ __ ] conspiracy
theory ideas
these [ __ ] wackadoos
so here we are here we sit watching them
tear each other apart
and they're mad they want unity
that's what the unity is about folks
they don't want us to point out
they're crazy they don't want
they don't want their crazy pointed out
by the democrats
because the democrats have said look
kevin mccarthy if you don't take
if you don't take this marjorie taylor
green off committee assignments
we will we will do it and then she
threatens oh if you do that ooh
watch out when we win in 2022. well you
have to [ __ ] win something here
before you before you can say oh well
we'll take democrats out of committee
assignments
and i don't think people understand um
just how effective taking a congress
person's committee assignments away from
them
actually is it is a big deal
you get elected to congress to have
committee assignments
like that's the whole [ __ ] point
the whole point there's not a lot of
[ __ ] you can do
for your constituency if you do not have
a committee assignment
there's not a lot of stuff you can trade
away to other members
and their committees this stuff will
handicap her pretty damn fast
if you guys i've talked about this
before but
you you remember in recent history uh
just a few years ago kevin mccarthy took
all of steve king of iowa all of his
committee assignments away from him
uh not only did it handicap steve king
it pretty much
he faded off into the distance and
a just as racist maga republican in iowa
beat him in the primary
but he wasn't so overtly racist
i mean he wouldn't post his racism so
blatantly on
facebook and twitter like this [ __ ]
steve king he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's a
racist he likes being a racist he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
same way with this marjorie taylor green
i keep saying my tick tock videos why is
it jewish space lasers
well we know why it's jewish space
lasers
she's a [ __ ] bigoted racist fascist
nazi
that's why that's why they're jewish
i mean they're not really space lasers
but it only adds it only adds to the
anti-semitic trope
by calling them jewish of course she's a
[ __ ] racist
of course she is jesus christ this lady
is
so so far from reality
she thinks 911 was a hoax she thinks
sandy hook
and and other prominent school shootings
and other shootings in this country
including las vegas and
stoneman douglas high were false flags
that was all it's not fake it's just an
attempt to take away her guns
and she's not the only one she's not the
only one that believes this stuff
and she's definitely not the only one
that pretends to believe this stuff
that's that's the trouble here
like steve scalise saying today well we
really we have to review this and
we have to we have to meet on this and
we really have to come to terms and
decide what we're going to do no you
don't have to decide what you're going
to do
you have to play pretend that you
believe it and you don't believe
it you're trying to play both sides here
we get it
we know what's happening
so if you [ __ ] want unity and
you [ __ ]
want to govern all right fine
we'll do that but we have to hold these
people accountable
first get justice for january 6
and make sure anyone doesn't matter if
it was a private citizen a member of the
military a member of the
capitol police members of congress of
the senate
if they were responsible hold them
accountable even the president of united
states
this trial is gonna happen and they're
gonna have witnesses
whether you [ __ ] like it or not
and when we get on the other side of
this accountability in the next
10 to 12 months and we can see what
accountability and justice actually
looks like for the events on january 6
that you [ __ ] stoked
and you brought down upon our country it
didn't work
i don't know what your end game was but
you can't even figure out what your end
game is now so spare me the cancer talk
mitch mcconnell
because people like lauren beaubert josh
holly ted
cruz and this marjorie taylor green
and all these q anon supporters in this
country
these [ __ ] maga maggots
they're just a symptom you're the
[ __ ] disease